I think the hound and Arya that'll be a
fantastic TV show it'll be so much
better than Kara - in children murder
mayhem and you know amazing fantastic
actress I think Aria should have her own
reality TV show and it'll be some sort
of game show revolving around all the
people she wants to kill you know and he
ever loses on weekly basis get stabbed
needle yeah and that's after Japan good
I'll be okay
so Japanese shoe because tickin with the
pointy end yeah maybe par to be
interesting but we all want to know what
happened in there with the you know you
know we saw a bit of it but yeah if
there was a reality TV show we we had to
follow him everywhere maybe that'd be
interesting is is kind of it enigmatic
I'd love it if it was just like him Oh
making the team having a bit of a Tilo
you know maybe getting some friends
round and then suddenly going whoring
and they're certainly going for it as a
ringer the daughter of when I was about
to happen
Bron definitely because I think he'd be
a diva
I think he's akane the guy who did
he'd be the son organ or gala Colleen
Garrity yay the bill there'll be a lot
of tantrums I think that would be it
would be interesting to see what he
ingesting or twisted to see what
whatever he gets up to you probably have
to say Terry because Terry and his such
a he's got such smarts and he's so quick
witted and sense of humor and all the
rest Tyrion and Bronn I think people
have already discussed this I've heard
people telling me that Tyrion and bronze
should have reality not like the
producers it was like fans that were
like Tyrion and bran would feel great
it's been all sharing the Nights Watch
should ever my little their own show you
know what happens that class will black
brashley it's this platform to be
provably he's actually the only you know
good moral character in the whole story
looking after people who need care and
the last one fortune nice watch
I knew it cooks a lot for the rest of
the people sorry you never see why not
don't touch and see what it gets up to
in the pub you never really see that
you'd be doing drinking mostly drinking
drinking and just being a bit miserable
maybe like less Dennis wasn't a big
brother house okay Lloris obviously I
mean there's a complete sitter obviously
Laura's grooming tips and lifestyle tips
it would be really interesting to see
what Highgarden is like so if you could
go back with Loras and see Highgarden in
a realise TV show that would be
interesting a very beautiful to look at
imagine I would love to see a project TV
show but you did like a Spring Break
style show with Podrick where he goes
out and tries to like you know get
strong meets girls it could be amazing
blind date instead of Cilla black having
well they're deciding on the couples you
know and the ones that don't honor their
promise to marry the person they promise
well they know what to expect up they
know maybe Melisandre and Davos at home
in the kitchen Melisandre with a nice
apron on and Devas putting up a couple
of shelves